que sa chaîne bonsoir vous voudriez
qu'on retienne quoi de ce film un film
d'amour ou un film politique de ce
continue il ya plein de choses qui ne
soit pas politique
labourer politique rentrer dans la salle
la bête et politique tout est politique
mais là vous dénoncez la mondialisation
c'est à vous attaquer plutôt l'argent le
libéralisme les américains vivent ou
dénoncer l'intégrisme et finalement ce
qui va surpris dans votre film c'est que
ça se termine mal c'est une tragédie
pourquoi je sais c'est plutôt un
avertissement ça veut dire si vraiment
vous pensé au jeune et beau penser à
l'avenir
attention vous ne vais pas continuer à
faire ça moi j'ai pas de haine
j'ai pas de haine comme que les
américains avaient ils ont été mes
propres mais oui vous avez une haine
contre les intégristes mais à côté il ya
une collusion entre et l'argent et les
aciéristes et les américains et les
intégristes et d'ailleurs les
intégristes mais ils les ont bien aidés
une sorte d'alliance objective et
certainement jamais le moindre doute
tout le monde ça marche pour eux mais il
ya beaucoup de gens qui souffrent et et
les nouvelles générations c'est ça où il
faut faire un tout petit peu attention
votre mondialisation c'est pas très vrai
c'est pas très juste
ça c'est comme comment voulez-vous que
moi je crois qu'ils n'ont pas prévu
qu'au kosovo
milosevic allait faire ce qu'il a fait à
croire aimer il en juillet l'ont testé
en bosnie et puis d'un coup ils sont
surpris qu'il ait fait ça c'est pas
trilogie survient à votre film est ce
parce que vous avez eu le grand prix à
cannes il ya deux ans que vous pouvez
maintenant vous permettre de dire et de
faire des choses au cinéma que peu de
gens peuvent faire dans les pays du sud
dans ces gentils les pieds du sud parce
que si tu as des deals et peu de chose
qui est jeune qui a été un
un journaliste un critique de cinéma
très prisé et aussi avec ce ce que nous
avons fait au gré des années oui cette
33ème fields et 30 sec entend
aujourd'hui je fais mes 50 ans de cinéma
est ce que je vous propose de voir un
film qui est un film israélien qui est
en compétition également pour pour un
certain regard c'est un film d'amos
gitaï qui avait déjà fait you miom
s'appelle kadosh c'est son septième film
est là aussi il ya ce même thème de
l'intolérance est un film qui dénonce
l'emprise des religions l'a vu dans le
reportage de marie ce bureau tout à
l'heure en israël je vais me présenter à
8h30 amis c'est que c'est que c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup et que
j'admire beaucoup
alors regardons cet extrait de son film
où des hommes par des femmes riches en
métaux paris nous offrit à valby qu'un
les gars d'el un souci et slash à 1025
de l'inédit
la vie mais à quoi cela nous mccarey la
vie son temps mais fut un film
d'actualité qu'on va revoir intérieur
télérama dit de youssef chahine il est
roué comme un singe et il est sérieux
comme un artisan qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir de youssef chahine
c'est une bonne définition
j'aime beaucoup non merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à ce journal je
m'attends leone